pour soi il y a aussi des bonnes
nouvelles des événements qui confirme
que l'on peut croire au progrès dans le
domaine médical ce sont le diagnostic et
la technologie prénatal qui bénéficient
ces derniers temps des avancées les plus
spectaculaires
ainsi on vient d'apprendre qu'à lyon une
greffe de cellules a été réussi sur un
foetus de sept mois atteints d'un
déficit immunitaire mortels une greffe
effectuée donc dans le ventre de la mère
c'est une première mondiale réalisée il
ya quelques mois par le professeur
touraine à l'hôpital edouard herriot de
lyon est tenue secrète jusqu'ici à la
demande de la famille le bébé n'est
normalement depuis est encore dans une
bulle pour quelques mois
cette technique représente donc un
nouvel espoir pour les enfants bull
jusqu'ici on avait réussi des greffes
mais après la naissance c'est grâce à
cette technique que nous allons
rencontrer avec alain labouze et pierre
laurent constants un garçon de 12 ans en
pleine forme
il s'appelle certains sont condamnés à
mourir parce qu'incapable de se défendre
contre les infections
certes jour qui a aujourd'hui 12 ans l'a
échappé belle
les 18 premiers mois de sa vie il les a
passées dans une bulle il n'y avait pas
de donneur de moelle compatibles et puis
un jour à lyon on a tenté l'impossible
la greffe de tissus provenant de foetus
mort et ça a marché
au point que j'ai pas y laisser partir
chez les critiques solide pas comme un
abus parce que tu es moche un plastique
rien faire nous même moment je peux
retourner dans l'ain le temps infiniment
jeu plus fin d'après-midi avant qu'ils
valent les frères je vais pas tellement
d'espoir m'attaquer le relève son geste
elle
je sais qu'elle a glanée vide son
agresseur ses dépens c'est ici dans ce
laboratoire que l'on prépare les
cellules de foie et de thymus extraites
des foetus mort
à ce jour 50 et enfants ont pu être
greffés avec ses cellules 66% sont
définitivement guéri il y a à peu près
une centaine d'enfants à traiter chaque
année soit près naissance soit avant la
naissance par une greffe de cellules
foetales nous manquons de ces cellules
ce qui est important c'est que nous
soyons prévenus chaque fois qu'un foetus
décède dans une ville de france pour que
nous puissions faire le prélèvement est
organisée la transplantation
on n'a pas le droit d'utiliser des
foetus mort dit certains et pourtant
c'est la seule façon aujourd'hui de
sauver des enfants comme sergio